[Music]
I'm trying to help you find one of the
four
maybe two of the four you know that's
very hopeful we're in London
it's Hubert
oh you can call me
eventually hubby
where are you from wow okay you would
ask me when's your birthday and I know
what that means I know what where that
conversation is going do you know where
that do you ask that question no you
wouldn't ask for my birthday no
[Music]
Esther yeah
where you from
East London
Stone East London area okay yeah yeah
where are you from I'm from New York
okay what is East London what's the
comparison there's one thing that New
Yorkers do whenever we travel around as
we'll just compare it to like oh this is
like the Brooklyn of London this is like
the deli of
Leighton
um I don't you can't really compare East
London to New York I feel like certain
parts of New York is like London in
general but it's just like people from
East London where I find that were
really chilled with discomfortable Vibes
or a very like chilled and meta kind of
people so you're the type of people to
go and smoke weed I don't smoke weed but
you don't no I don't I don't my mother's
day and he does that which is so funny
but I don't smoke weed why don't you
smoke I just don't I've tried it and it
just doesn't work for me I just don't
like how I feel you get all anxious and
yeah I just don't like it okay do you
smoke I used to for a long time but now
I'm just like you I used to like make
fun of people that talk like us now
right I can't handle weed and like [__]
and I just I go I'll win do you drink
I I do commit Haram and drink yes I know
it's the last day of well second last
day of Ramadan yeah do drink okay so
what's your favorite drink
I like uh going classic right now I'm
feeling classy I'm wearing a nice shirt
I don't know if you see my shoes thank
you these shoes they're cute yeah
they're nice I feel like James Bond are
like uh so I've been drinking a whiskey
on the Rocks okay like sitting there
that means like straight right no the
Rocks means with ice oh with ice oh okay
cool okay okay what about you what do
you like doing for what's your Vice my
advice so as in what I do in my free
time what I enjoy
no what's your your cheat code you know
what's your way to because smoking like
what's your oh what's my oh what's your
degenerate thing that you enjoy doing I
like knitting and crocheting so I make
like beanies clothes that's not
degenerate at all that's so awesome
that's what I like yeah I find it very
like therapeutic relaxing yeah and
sometimes if my sister's there we'll
have like maybe a drink just to chill a
glass of Prosecco catch a Vibe play
music so stuff like that like I said I'm
really chilled I don't really I like
doing things that's chilled so that's
just me anyway so you're knitting having
a drink if I'm having a drink I may not
be knitting like I said if my sister's
there then we just catch a Vibe or my
cousin's glass of Prosecco play music
and just chill
obviously if she's not there I'm
literally always knitting and crocheting
and making did you know this this one no
but I haven't eaten other stuff that
I've won that would have been really
impressive yeah I can knit this but
because I bought this I was like I'm not
gonna knit something that I really have
if that makes sense but I can knit it
yeah then what do you do
that you're ashamed of this is a risky
question
do I do that I'm ashamed of you know
like what's up what's your way to relax
so you're not proud of you know because
this is something you could tell people
I knit you know this that's a first date
answer
what's like some group chat type stuff
that you and your girlfriends like you
know
do you understand what I'm saying no I
get what you mean
there you go oh I was like being at home
like just in my birthday soon if people
they obviously I wear like my dressing
up I like being free like sometimes just
yeah that's not that bad it's not that
bad but like that's that's normal you
like to why would you want to wear
clothes but yeah I do that and it's true
it's just in alone in your bed or like
with other people in the house no no in
my room if other people in my house I'm
not doing that no way okay yeah because
I know some girls like they'll just they
won't care the walk like hey yeah my
best friend's like that she's she's too
funny I've gone to her house and she's
opened the door I'm like really she's
like yeah I'm I'm free I'm in my house
I'm like okay do you do but you're in
the house too so it's a little bit it's
a bit weird but I'm just like nice cool
you don't like that does that bother you
because I'm like oh cool but it doesn't
love me no she's in her own house she's
this her body she can do what she wants
with it
so what type of
thoughts and feelings you have when you
see other female breasts
inside
[Music]
so you don't need you don't need to no
that why would I think you don't just
wanna no no no you don't just want to
like slap him I have I have enough of
mine so yeah it's really yeah I wouldn't
just go upstairs no okay
I I that that's what I want to do when I
see them walking around like yeah I just
want to just hey how you doing buddy hey
nice to see you you know come here oh a
long time no see yeah no I do yeah those
are the intrusive thoughts that's
another question I like asking people
I don't feel like I'm grilling you right
now and you could ask me a question but
what type of uh intrusive thoughts you
have
sometimes if I see like a guy with a
nice poem I wanted to say grab it okay
there you go yeah I don't I don't do it
in my head I'm like um
he's got a nice Peach bun because all
women like a guy with a nice bomb I
didn't get that why I don't know it's
just something to grab onto it's just
like oh hi
why not like shoulders no but it's
obviously you can show those you can
always grab them but it's just nice to
have a bomb it's like guys they like
women with a bit of bum like it's just
they just like jiggle it because there's
something to do with it that that's
where every that's where all the good
stuff is
there's nothing like there's nothing
here like what I think a guy having a
good bum is nice it's a nice thing
you just want to just grab it yeah
yeah same way you'll grab mine if he
sees
you in certain clothes like if your guy
looks good you just want to be like oh
babe like you look really good I just
want to arrest him oh babe
so you don't do that no you're like hey
babe come here no I didn't sound like
that your voice Got Deep when you said
that did it yeah oh babe you've got a
nice no I've got a nice bum in it
we don't say anything like that say it
again in it why do you say it he's got a
nice bum in it but you're saying it with
an accent are you just in it yeah just
you know not in it
come here with your bum in it all right
sorry I'm done well tell me another
intrusive thought
hmm
everyone has their sports but yeah
I immediately think of of racial slurs
when I see anybody
what do you mean why that's I I don't
know why
no matter who's sitting down and who I'm
talking to it's just immediately so as
soon as you saw me you had a thought no
because I'm not really because you have
straight hair and I'm not really sure
like what's your ethnicity
your mix I'm Jamaican but yeah what's
the other so my mom my both parents are
Jamaica my mom's got it's like a
throwback Chinese Indian and my dad's
got Indian and German but it's more of a
throwback so yeah just Jamaican yeah so
you're like a you're a mutt you're kind
of like me so it's just I didn't really
there's nothing good enough
yeah why there's so many Chinese people
in Jamaica it's because they're um
they're either out there for work so
they're like building like toll roads so
people when you drive through you have
to pay but there are a lot of Chinese
out there and they're all called Mr
Ching if you're going to a shop a bit
well Grandma's Kitchen Mr Chang Mr Chen
yeah that's what they call them out
there I was in Jamaica like a month ago
if you saw that in America you would get
called racist they're literally called
Mr chairman
that's just how it is quite a few
engines as well there's some Caucasians
out there but in Chinese or like they're
taken over there's a lot of Jamaicans in
London right
quite a few here can you tell me some of
the slang I love saying one book
ladies I love that so it is wrong you
guys are really good with your
homophobia oh yeah in Jamaica yeah
they're a bit like butter for me
I just think that's the cause of their
lifestyle and how it is out there
they're just a bit like it's a bit much
but if I feel like if they come over
here and live in like in London and see
like gay people it it's not it doesn't
bother me I don't really mind but
obviously in Jamaica it's a big thing
like
that I know oh so you you like those
people it's not that I I wouldn't say I
don't I just don't have an issue if
that's what they're into that's what
they're into I'm not going to judge them
just because they're gay or they're
non-binary that's their preference and
that's their lifestyle
non-binary yeah I don't have it's not my
I don't feel like it's right to judge
people you know it's really stupid about
non-binary
is that actually creates a binary
because non-binary implies that there is
a binary So when you say there's binary
and non-binary that's what that is yeah
a binary it's so stupid it's so they've
created this thing like there's normal
people and there's different people yeah
and so different people like queer
whatever this thing it's and so now
you've made a new one and then you know
what's going to happen soon there's
going to be a non-binary for those
non-bind because that's the new binary
yeah yeah and there's going to be a new
Rainbow thing I don't even know what
colors they're going to use
it's crazy because there is a lot going
on within the LGBT it's all over London
it's just it hasn't affected East London
um
not where I live no not the area that I
live in I can't speak for the whole of
East London but my area no no okay maybe
I just see it really polarize on social
media I'm seeing all these like stairs
on the train getting painted oh that's
in some stations especially when there's
um Pride coming up they they push it a
lot they promote it obviously like
Primark will do t-shirts places will put
the rainbow sign up you'll see Flags I
think that's just when it comes closer
to that time but like I said for where I
live you don't really see what do you
think about Pride
you know it's one of the seven deadly
sins yeah and they made it a month of
Celebration
where we all need to partake in it they
block off streets they go
say Carnival carnivals like a couple
days and Carnival's not Pride Carnival
celebrations yeah they're they're
showing they're saying let's be proud of
how we touch each other's genitals like
there's literally celebrating degeneracy
yeah and they're being proud of it and
they're saying again it's the the world
we live in now a lot of things are being
pushed and a lot of people are being
desensitized I think I just think it's
it's just how the world is the world is
can I swear like a [__] up place like
it is just what it is like there's so
much [__] that's going on I feel like
sometimes they sometimes you got to put
your foot down and be a threat that is
well and sometimes they push things to
kind of
to take your focus off what's really
going on in the world it's all
distraction yeah basically it's okay
so how about the scenario
we're married we have a kid yeah we have
a two-year-old son
and I tell you
I want to change my gender and I'm
leaving the marriage hey you yeah I'm
not I'm gonna become a woman I'm gonna
become a woman I'm gonna start taking
estrogen I'm gonna go cut off this
and you got to raise the Sun and there's
a minute left but this is very important
part
what are you doing
um to be fair because I married you and
you're my husband I will always support
you I'm your wife now well yeah I would
I would support you in your choice and
what you do because I think that they
are married you because I fell in love
with your energy your Vibe of your
personality if you choose to change that
that's you but it wouldn't stop me from
loving you because you were who I love
from the beginning until now so you
wouldn't be like actually I married you
because I wanted you to be the man yeah
obviously you I wanted you to be the
husband I want you to be the father and
if you're not playing that role
bye I don't love you anymore because you
are not literally you are not the man
that I married literally
no I don't think I would do that
so you're gonna accept you you would
stay in the relationship not that I
would I'm not saying I would stay you
would say stay in the house and we'll
both be wives and paint each other's
nails
thing is I'm not really I'm not in that
speak sorry about that it's very
possible you're talking about the world
we're in now oh no but if it was to
happen I would support my husband wife
whatever the situation is I will support
them it's just how I am as a person so
what about the kid the kid um that's my
kid I'm loving my kid I'll bring up my
kid do the best for my kid my child
yeah what would you do if it was flipped
if it was flipped
no
no okay I refuse
you're staying my wife and we're raising
this kid we made a commitment to God and
to this child
you have to stay my wife okay and if you
want to do that I'm not supporting you
you're cut off forever
and keeping my kid away from those
nonsense because that's not what we
signed up to do okay no I'm
authoritarian
okay
thank you thank you it was nice speaking
to you was that too much of a
disagreement are you that's no second
date no we can have a second date oh
okay yeah good definitely I'll see you
soon Esther the Jamaican girl
I like that
she didn't get triggered when I said no
no
to that nonsense that we brought up with
you that was good that she's willing to
uh look past that she doesn't get that
triggered by something that's anti-woke
she had uh
whoa I thought she knit that shirt
because that was those things were
those things I really wanted to go like
just just in the middle of the day I got
the she said she has the intrusive
thoughts about I I wanted to
I just wanted to pounce on it but no she
was good nice nice I was looking in her
eyes trying not to look down I liked her
I would say
[Music]
um
yeah I'm interested in I want to see see
more of the girls man but uh both I
would say absolutely it was like a six
out of ten days you're a little nervous
but that's good I like when a girl's
nervous and she's cheapest and she's
trying to qualify herself because uh
this is I'm in my element right now so
you've had the reason how about
it oh yeah off camera yes yeah on camera
no yeah
yeah I mean like gay people bisexual
trans yeah I love everybody you love
everybody yeah I Believe In Love Speech
you better give me a cheat kiss okay